hallo mein name ist heidi
ich habe super neuigkeiten für alle
fenster hallo deutsche schule
neu kannst du mitglied unseres youtube
kanals werden
wie funktioniert das
es gibt drei stufen
stufe 1 kostet nur 0 franken 95 im monat
du kannst jedes video eine woche früher
sehen
du bekommst images für den chat
wir korrigieren und beantworten deine
kommentare
stufe 2 kostet 1 franken 95 im monat
alles von stufe 1 ist inklusive
wir posten exklusiven content in der
community
es gibt einen live stream im monat
stufe 3 kostet 5 franken 95 im monat
alles von den stufen 1 und 2 ist
inklusive
du bekommst zugang zu unserer
lernplattform
wir geben dir ein blick hinter unsere
kulissen
mit der kanal mitgliedschaft unterstützt
du die halle deutsche schule
so können wir weiterhin jeden tag unser
bestes für dich geben
klicke jetzt auf den mitglied werden
button
für unsere bestehenden abonnenten ändert
sich übrigens nichts
alle nichtmitglieder bekommen weiterhin
jeden sonntag ein neues video und
regelmäßige post